comme épine au pied ou des prisons
dès lors la vista
lamia mutati dalo
que tu regardes crise une bien jolie
chemise à temps
très bien voir ce qu'il ya là où ça me
ferait pas peur tu sais pas dire en
cours tu crois ça oui je te regarde et
upc l'eau du pouvoir
non
pourquoi thierry comme ça pourriez vous
l'ayez j'ai un conseil était demandé
écoutez je crois que je vais me marier
avec qui je vais te le dire parce que tu
vas me donner à dresser avec qui je sais
pas s'il convient de saisir si tu veux
pas le dire garde-toi le jeu laissait
déjà c'est le petit victor tout le monde
l'a vu est venu te parler tous les soirs
sous prétexte magie des coquillages il a
mangé tellemint qu'il a failli mourir de
l'urticaire
qu'est-ce que ça pro et ça prouve que
c'était même mais s'il est si tu comptes
sur le magasin son père est pas encore
mort si tu sais je souhaite après avoir
personne et je me moque bien de victo
alors qui sait panis
à l'issue
le prêt à organiser monsieur panis
tu ne me crois pas non
bon alors tu ne veux pas me donner un
conseil si je te conseille la prochaine
fois que tu voudras me faire marcher de
chercher histoire moins de bateaux que
celle là